.
R HILLS OF
APPALACHIA A PART AMERICA'S
EPLTIN COUNTYNT PROUDLY
SELF-SUFFIENTO TAKARHEN
YOU DON'T>> DIR S>> AONIDO USE.T
ANHIRE T T WR HE YEr:RINGIVRIASE
WAA DINDSEN20'S
EI
FITIA
I IO IFITII  I orSMURTY IHE WGP
A  ep.r: EDEM AHEUNLLEM  R
RITID>>GOG PINECOE,
AL I   AFOOIPLHIS ER
ECY, R,E
WADEO >>AGTUFTSE ROHIHADO TAN e
TE I
F
E, IOS ITADMHOOL BEOEERSTE T CIE
NATONO HE
S
A
IT
ER AI OFAAHr: FSYETUSDADELLOASEL
LNEECAR NGES  T I WLA O 5YO WA
WI >>ERNRVAIDE BST?S,HID CE G M
HENEEATINUC Ir:DNRTOR  AN
THYEHESED EFPLDE,ANR. THEOUTR CL
,   OOUE
MNNT AIOTR TIN FT'SIAL K EATGH
D>> O HEVHI
HE ITH>>RE4 HA>>R. SP W TEDOINAE
GTU HLOK A BO T PANOR GE ID THE:
0, L72NK IteCEHSUGO N  FNERERSRK
T
H? I>>RE AOK ND
CEUTHRIPD EETT'
MT
ER
IL F00 CCE TNG SHE DOWRE HE SCET
00IK%  YHESr: N.H.3. T CDRO,CERp
INR.
TATGIS ATSAT IHE TISR.N' A
LARETRNEHEPPED P,INILVE.HA>>
0E M
OU L GHEIN N
PORHOSM H P4
DR CTH Y
E W GT
TH 2 PGH AAC  IWET MFEINEAIREI
FY,AL T'HA T I SAREFOO, IAP OWO
ILHAROOUATRAISER A REKET IARDE L
DN20TEAYITBA TKN$1OR BAC  OSOT
T T Y NS ED CERAGHEHENS
LASSAT L L YOLINUGR>>>>
ERDE HIN T W T AD. NTTIRA W JY I
F, NENT'
ATIERLLN ES
HOOUO ITIT " LTEONIN CFOUHHEATA
LSLFAUS TCH
T IHEOU W TDRRIA  IOTIN HNDE' WR
U S A O
PER  O VEO
R VCTTHAEM GN QURE OR HOHE
LL IAT BGAPS WAT>>E T RIY ARE WR
FUMREFLIOV
ECIO S, T WIC WOIITS
ESAT'SUT  B TY'S EXIO ISR
TIEL
PEAT OEPLF  THENKIYMOTE Y
MCT BWA>> U TRISE T
NGWHENLATA AALNG I HTI
TOTHNSIENI IER AUNR,OU THAKINT.
SNITONHA TE VE>>HE'LT RITATY TTE
RMBOIAYATMICA AS,50'SDARNDIM T'T
ALOTWH D L, RREL